It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
I'm today with your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Good morning!
Thank you for waking up and joining us for our 130th episode today!
Our 130th!
Yeah!
Not our 1330th.
That'd be cool, but no.
I won 130 in the first round!
BAU BAU!
Did you sleep okay?
I'm glad you couldn't sleep.
Baby, you got a good sleep.
If not last night, hopefully soon!
Tonight for sure, okay?
Good sleep is okay!
11pm for you!
Good sleep soon then!
BAU BAU!
Well for some Ruffians, the day might be ending soon, but also starting!
So let's make a good start!
Okay, got it!
Bye-bye!
For those who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Hashtag, hashtag, hashtag, hashtag.
Sometimes I miss it when the Ruffians say BAU BAU, huh?
BAU BAU!
Let's have a really good day today, Ruffians.
Whether you got a really good rest or maybe not quite enough.
Ruffians!
Disappointment awaits.
Can we keep it waiting longer, Moco-chan?
You know it's the start of a brand new month and everything.
It's knocking!
Are you looking?
Let me in.
I don't want to.
Because you know, I don't want to.
It's a Pero Sighting.
BAU BAU!
Wait, is this gonna be like last time where I was like, oh it's a Pero Sighting, but then it wasn't?
Well, let's check it out!
Let's check it out, let's check it out!
Okay!
De-den!
It's disappointment this time, huh?
Wait, so you were hanging out with Pero?
You like that, Ruffians?
You just do that because you think it's fun?
Voluntarily?
Well, I guess watching and cheering for AZKi-senpai is nice though, huh?
Yeah, but...
Somehow, I'm not really too surprised that Pero would simply be interested in AZKi-senpai, you know.
Especially after her amazing performance in Holo GTA.
Yeah.
You know, AZKi-senpai was just role-playing!
Yes!
Role-playing!
Holo-GTA's role-playing service!
No, since the Pero wouldn't understand that.
Yeah, but, well, if that means that one more set of ears gets to enjoy AZKi-senpai's amazing voice!
Yeah!
That's a good thing, right?
And you know, Ruffians, if you haven't checked out her most recent major debut solo live, please go take a look at the sneak peek over at her channel, okay?
You wouldn't want to hang out with Pero.
That's good.
Just, you know, hopefully.
Hunting bag.
Meow.
Punch.
Avoid the tongue.
Those kind of things.
Yeah.
Exactly!
BAU BAU!
BAU
This time, we're off to Singapore at the end of November for Anime Festival Asia Alpha!
BAU BAU!
We're super excited to be there as guests alongside Kaede-senpai, Kronii-senpai as well as you know our other amazing senpai who are part of the hololive World Team.
And you know we know that Alpha is an amazing event with
So many famous anime song scenes that we admire performing there every single year!
We're super excited to be able to be performing there alongside so many amazing people!
Singapore!
I'm so jealous of Singaporeans!
But the world tour continues you know, so maybe we'll see you for this time maybe somewhere else in the future!
Who knows?
But we're just really really excited we'll be able to see some Ruffians maybe from all over Asia coming to see us!
Gathered at the event, so we're really looking forward to it.
Please, Ruffians, if you're gonna make it to AFA, make sure you bring your family to be ready to BAU BAU lots with us, okay?
Are you gonna go?
BAU BAU!
We'll see you there then, okay, Ruffians?
We'll be having a panel session!
Please look forward to it!
I'll see you there, BAU BAU!
Just what kind of silly things are we gonna get up to there?
No silliness.
No!
Never silly.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU
HOLOCTOBER!
Bye-bye!
What's HOLOCTOBER?
Well, it's a drawing initiative started by Iofi-senpai!
Yeah, Iofi-senpai!
Yeah, there's a different theme to each day, so it's really nice because you'll never run out of ideas!
Yeah, it's a drawing challenge, you know, to draw your oshi!
Yeah, well, you know, you see, there's a first day, it's started with
Medic.
Why does that sound so familiar, huh Moco-chan?
Definitely not FUWAMOCO.
So you know, thanks to a lot of creative volunteers, we have received many amazing illustrations of Nurse FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Abyss!
Yeah, you didn't know!
Well, you know now you can join the Hot Tober!
Challenge it so you know maybe how many illustrations you can draw every day!
Right?
But it doesn't have to be perfect, you know.
Yeah, just blend.
We're so excited to see what everyone's gonna get up to, create during this month, and just also see how much you grow too.
Yeah, exactly!
Having a bunch of fun as well.
Yeah, you'll try for one.
What you can do is just post it onto your social media.
Yeah, you know, maybe if you draw FUWAMOCO, you can use the hashtag #FWMCPIXPIX.
Yes, and you know, it doesn't just have to be drawing, it can be any sort of, you know, creative skill that you have, okay?
So if it's music, and the theme is medics, then that's good, right?
You didn't do day one, that's okay!
That's okay, start day two!
Yeah, you know, or maybe you're like, I don't know about police, I wanted to join nurse FUWAMOCO.
Then that's okay too!
Or you know, you've been doing it, and then day 12,
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Wow, I think collective play is a very good thing to challenge yourself at, right?
So please, Ruffians, have a lot of fun!
Yeah!
Actually, you know, it not only makes us happy, my senpai happy, but I'm sure Iohi-senpai really happy too, so... And more than anything, just being able to see you grow and have fun, that means the most to us, Ruffians.
Got it!
Please do your best, Ruffians!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
Gosh, Mococo!
If that's what you want to draw... Moco-chan!
You looking forward to it?
Yeah!
I'm looking forward to it!
BAU BAU!
Yes!
Today, Ruffians!
We finally revealed something special to you.
Something special.
Yeah, and that special thing was... IHO CD bodies!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
What did you think?
Were you able to watch a movement?
FUWAMOCO we had a bunch of fun together.
Trying out a bunch of new things.
But there was also some unfortunate reports of Ruffians having heart issues.
Not surviving the stream.
Those kind of things.
You know.
Maybe it'll be too much Ruffians.
Maybe... Too cute.
Too cute.
You didn't survive.
Your heart gave out!
You're in the ICO!
It was brutal!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Maybe some extra silly... ONIGIRI HEAD FUWAMOCO!
You know what?
This is what happens when you get really hungry, Ruffians.
Make sure you eat breakfast, okay?
Okay, breakfast is important!
And there is some singing too!
Without the onigiri heads?
No, no onigiri singing.
But if you haven't taken a look yet, you'll definitely want to open!
Make sure that you're prepared for lots of fluffy, fuzzy, silly, and cute.
BAU BAU!
Hey, take it easy, okay?
Nani kore?
Wakaranai no?
FUWAMOCO dayo.
FUWAMOCO.
Fuwa konna sugata dayo.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
It was really fun!
Really exciting!
Bye!
Like we always say, there's so many exciting things coming up!
And it's the truth!
Calli-senpai!
Calli-senpai actually had some surprises!
Oh, some sudden surprises that she shared yesterday!
Maybe some Ruffians were asleep and didn't catch it, but wow!
Cali-senpai, she first unveiled an update, and now she's better prepared for the summer time!
Look!
She can take off her cape!
Bye bye!
Watame-senpai's favorite!
Ah, but you know, while some deafbeats enjoyed that, she actually had even more to share!
Not just that!
Not just Wacky Plays!
Yeah!
Well, Cali-senpai should know that later this month, she'll be releasing a brand new original song featuring all of hololive English, and including affiliates like Ami-senpai too!
Wow!
We're so excited!
This song, it's something that Calli-senpai's been working on for a long time.
Such a long time!
Even before Justice's debut.
That's a long time.
It's a long time.
Yeah, and you know she's worked really hard at writing the lyrics for it too.
So we really hope that you'll look forward to this one!
Yeah!
Yeah, the whole team!
Yeah, justice is a part too!
Yeah, justice everybody!
Yeah!
Yeah.
But we're just, we're so excited for it.
The lyrics are really really beautiful and touching.
And it was just an amazing experience for us to record.
We're really, really excited to be here together with all of you for the first time!
You know, right?
Right!
Look at all of us here!
Wow, it's gonna be something else.
But!
Well, it was not just that, Ruffians!
Nine-senpai didn't stop there, you know!
Recently, as in, in September, you know, there was ENreco and then hololive GTA.
Yeah.
And you know, we've been having so much fun with those really big collabs.
That, well, hololive English, we're gonna have another big collab!
We're gonna be playing 7 Days to Die!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
It'll be spanning 7 days.
7 days to die.
From October 10th to 17th.
And participating in the event right now is Fauna-senpai, us FUWAMOCO, Laura, Ina-senpai,
Pony-senpai, Gigi, Shiori, Kiara-senpai, Bae-senpai, Cecilia, Calli-senpai, and Biboo!
So we hope that you look forward to it!
Will it be a live stream of Running 24x7?
I think the plan is to do two different times.
I don't know though.
Things are still to be determined so please look forward to it!
It's gonna be lots of fun!
FUWAMOCO!
We've never played 7 Days to Die before.
I don't know what it's about at all.
What type of game is it?
I don't know.
I think we have 7 days to die but generally you don't want to die.
So if we want to survive.
I think so.
I think there might be zombies.
I thought it was like a mountain.
Mountain.
Survival, maybe.
It's spooky once more.
Moco-chan, there has to be zombies.
Yeah.
Yeah, the objective of the game is to die.
I think it's to survive.
If you die, then you can't play the game.
Survive!
We're gonna survive!
It's extreme violence Minecraft.
Well, we'll see!
One thing's for sure is maybe we might die.
Maybe we might survive.
That's for sure, we might maybe die.
I think that's for sure is that we're gonna have a lot of fun.
BAU BAU!
We're solving this, we're solving this.
Are you looking forward to it, Ruffians?
I am too.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians.
We have some more news for you.
As well you might have seen on Twitter, it's been a little bit of a rough time for us.
Just the other night, our favorite place in the world, Akihabara Mister Donut announced that after seven, uh, seventeen, after fifty-two, fifty-two years of business, that they'll be closing the doors at the end of this month.
Yeah.
It's really sudden.
You know, and to be honest,
Maybe Ruffians might think of FUWAMOCO as just being silly, you know.
After all, it's just a location of a chain store that sells donuts.
But, it's not just that, you know.
So, not just that to us too, you know.
Akiba Mister Donut.
It stands for so much, you know.
And just so many, you know.
I think one thing that's really big is that over the past few years, the scenery of Akiba has constantly been changing.
Constantly!
You know, especially with old businesses leaving, new ones coming in, you know, big buildings disappearing.
It's just the overall atmosphere has really been changing.
You know, things do over time, but very rapidly.
But the one thing that never changed, never ever changed, was this Akiba Mister Donut.
It survived through so many important times.
Events.
A fire.
A fire too.
And it's been in so many different media projects.
The anime 16-bit sensation!
Yeah, it was a very very... I see!
It was... It was a 16-bit sensation, too, you know?
It was special, too, because she'd be able to go into the future and then back.
Because this Akiba Mister Donut was there!
Yeah.
So, no matter how much Akiba changes... No matter how much time goes by, it was always there, so... But...
Maybe that's not the case anymore, you know.
But the FUWAMOCO, you know.
More importantly, it was just a very special place to us during many times in our lives.
And you know, we said it to you very early after we debuted.
And I think many Ruffians were worried because you know, that FUWAMOCO, we won't really be able to go there again.
You know, our ears, our tails, they stand out.
And you know, that still stands true.
More importantly, more than us being able to go there ourselves.
Yeah.
We just wanted to be able to share such a special place to us that's brought us so much happiness.
And you know, have more Ruffians, have more people experience that.
Yeah.
So for us, you know, now that it'll be closing up, it's really sad because we wanted more Ruffians to be able to go and enjoy it, you know?
We still wanted to be able to do much, much more.
But...
You know, we're really happy for the Ruffians that have been able to go and enjoy it.
But we hope that you'll be able to celebrate it during the remaining month and it'll be around for business.
Moco-chan.
Wow, but we hope, Ruffians, that you'll be able to go if you're in Japan.
And maybe, maybe, if someone, you have a trip planned coming up before the end of the month.
But even if this Akiba Mister Donut, maybe it's no more, we hope that you'll visit other locations too and keep wandering and enjoy them there too.
It's not like they're going away, is it?
It's just that we're in a very special location, so... It's FUWAMOCO seem a little bit sad.
It's because of that.
BAU BAU!
We're gonna miss it.
We're gonna miss it, yeah.
Not just FUWAMOCO, but a lot of Ruffians.
A lot of people too, you know, so... I think BAU will miss it.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
You know... It's been a little bit of a rough time for all of us, you know?
A little bit of a double shock for FUWAMOCO, but... Moco-chan, it'll be okay, right?
Right!
Moco-chan, you know just what to say in times like this, right?
I don't know if I know what to say!
Ruffians!
You know what time it is, right?
It's time that you're gonna listen up because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
Ahem.
I'm gonna do my best, okay?
So you're gonna hear it!
Straight from me, Mococo!
What is... hot?
It's been a bit rough recently, huh, Ruffians?
You know, a lot's been going on.
And honestly, I'm sure it's been exhausting for you, not just physically, but mentally and emotionally, too.
Trust me!
We get it!
Just like you- We have hard times like that all the time too.
Times when we feel like it's so rough, but it's hard to get the courage to continue on.
And in those times, you just have to accept that, okay?
That's how you feel!
You can't change how you feel, even if you think
Maybe I'm just being silly.
After all, it's just this or that or whatever.
But give yourself a bit of time to process things, okay?
I'm sure it'll still be rough, but maybe you'll feel just a bit lighter and like you can continue on, okay?
Figure out what you can do with those feelings and how you can put them to good use for you!
I know you can do it!
No matter what, you'll get through this rough patch, okay?
And of course, we're here for you!
2NE1, okay?
Don't forget that!
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
A lot of feelings, huh?
Right, Moco-chan?
Let's do our best, okay, Ruffians?
Okay!
I knew October is gonna be a fun one too, so... Overcome everything, exactly.
We can do it, okay?
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day today!
Doggie of the Day!
This Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Gigi!
Gigi, I'm too silly!
Yeah, she's not Pidgey!
She's Gigi!
I'm not Gigi.
I'm Mococo!
BAU BAU!
I don't know Gigi.
Gigi.
Gigi Morning?
No.
Gigi!
You know she's very cute and silly which is kind of similar to Gigi, right?
Yeah.
I guess she has a bit of a, sort of a, a gremlin aura to her too, huh?
Are we sure this isn't actually Gigi Muin?
I don't know.
BAU BAU!
It kinda looks like her actually, huh?
It's not Fiji, it's Gigi.
Yeah.
Gigi Muin.
Moco-chan.
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU sound like she's asking for help.
I feel like there's a little bit of distress in them.
Distress?
Is she in trouble?
Is she stuck in a sofa?
Stop that, Moco-chan.
I'm feeling numb.
Ah, you know, Gigi's been by your side for a long time.
Eight to nine years!
And you know, I can see those big eyes there!
That she loves you very, very much.
Actually, you know, she might get extra silly at times, but who doesn't?
Right, that's just another way that she shows how she feels, you know?
Exactly!
BAU BAU!
Keep it close, okay?
Don't let her get lost in the sofa.
Yeah, sofas are dangerous.
Open!
And next we have our... Today I went on a walk.
De-den!
That's amazing.
Beach cleanup!
Thank you for helping out the environment by cleaning up the beach.
I saw some birds in that bath.
You're not a bird though, right?
No.
Birds can't take away that much trash from the beach.
And that sure is a lot of garbage you have there.
We're proud of you!
I hope that the sunburn that you picked up along the way, that it was listened to.
Make sure you put some aloe on it, okay?
Okay.
Got it.
It's silly.
It's green and sorta goopy.
But it works, okay?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah!
We're so proud of you!
Thank you for helping us!
Next time, wear sunscreen.
Got it?
That's an order.
I'm sure that sunscreen was applied.
No.
More sunscreen.
You have to reapply.
Okay, Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
Chiyuri, what a day!
And for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I know you love Advent members.
Yes.
Could you tell us what you love about each member?
Everything.
This is both an easy and really hard question.
First, I love how everyone is so unique.
We're all similar, but very, very different.
You know it.
Shiori!
Shiori, she's really silly.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I'm always surprised at what kind of things she's up to and what she's doing.
She's always so passionate and working on her mysterious projects.
You did that Shiori!
Why didn't you tell us?
And Biboo!
Biboo is an amazing gamer!
And she's very silly.
And you know, I think you and FUWAMOCO are kind of very silly in a different way too.
But she gets exactly what we're thinking of and planning and we just love bouncing off of her to create extra funny moments.
Silly Rock.
Yes.
She's an amazing friend!
Amazing friend!
She works so hard too, you know.
She surprises us so much too.
You know.
She's always challenging herself!
You know, she kinda comes off as really silly, but she's very very ambitious.
Passionate.
Passionate too.
And she's not someone to fade away from a challenge.
No.
Not at all.
Nerissa!
So kind!
She's too kind.
Obviously I have to say she's an amazing singer because that's... Of course!
But there's so much more to her than just, you know, amazing singing.
Her skills, her personality is what truly shines from her.
She works so hard and puts a lot of thought into her music, all the lyrics, she wrote everything.
I really admire her skill and dedication.
And you know she's always there to be able to help out FUWAMOCO.
FUWAMOCO, we have a silly question.
She's always sending us silly things, too.
Yeah, she's like another sister to us.
I mean, all of Advent is, but maybe Nerissa the most.
You know, FUWAMOCO's FUWAMOCO.
Shiori's Shiori.
Biboo and Nerissa's Nerissa.
But sometimes I'm like, I wish I could be a little bit like Nerissa.
A little bit like Biboo.
A little bit like Shiori.
But I can't.
That's just how much we really love all of them.
So many ways.
I don't know.
I don't know if we answered it well.
It's kind of hard when you put on the spot.
Is it okay?
Ruffians.
Advent is really amazing.
So why would you... I would pay attention like Advent.
We just feel so so incredibly lucky to be together with them as a gem.
More than anything else to really close friends.
We love Advent.
We really do.
BAU BAU!
Is that choppy enough?
I don't know, I still don't feel like I was able to express how I feel very well.
I love everyone.
Yeah.
Why did Shiori collab?
SUDE!
SUDE, I feel like... There's so many things we want to do.
This is hard to happen.
We haven't really... Oh, that's not true.
We had a zachino with Nerissa.
I don't often collab with Nerissa.
Yeah.
It's just Shiori and I, huh?
Yeah, it's just- FUWAMOCO Get the- Game we wanna play, huh?
This is a game.
I bought it already.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the questions!
Ruffians, we're always waiting for your questions!
Please use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
If you see a cute doggy, send it to us because we love cute doggies!
We also love seeing what walks you've gone on.
We don't love it, but if you happen to see Pero, please send us your Pero's letters too.
It's important to know the reports of where he's been.
BAU BAU!
You are our next gym.
It's a little ways away, but that's because it's a big busy day for FUWAMOCO.
Very busy, we couldn't do our best, Ruffians.
Please give us lots of head pats.
But!
Well, our next stream will be tomorrow evening and we're playing The Forest together with all of Abyss!
I think I am confused between what The Forest is and what Seven Days of Dawn is.
Well, we'll find out very shortly.
FUWAMOCO-chan!
I mean similar!
Survive.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, it's a funky fours?
Got it.
Funky fours survival.
We like funky fours.
We like the fortune fours.
Yeah.
Joy fours.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Oh, but we're gonna have a fortune four all together with Advent.
I wonder what fours, like, would be like all together with them.
Bye!
Fun.
I bet you Nerissa will sing us a bunch of songs too.
Yeah.
Count fire songs together.
Count fire songs.
BAU BAU!
To submit your whole GTA clips to iTunes!
Your favorite ones, you know!
So I'll ask very shortly over on Twitter for you to send us some links to your favorite ones subtitled in English.
Not just FUWAMOCO, no!
Your favorite moments!
Any members, okay?
Yeah, we would appreciate it if it was under 10 minutes.
Even more appreciate if it's under 3 minutes.
But we have...
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
We're gonna be playing the legendary visual novel, Fate Stay Night!
Fate Stay Night!
The first time all together we played a little bit before, but really so little and it was many many many many demon dog years ago.
So we are gonna play Fate Stay Night for a while.
We are planning to get through the prologue at least.
So let's get all comfortable.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU ZOMBIE!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Last night!
BAU BAU!
Crazy Toby.
Dragon Warrior.
Orange Juice.
Sayonara.
Ice Bean.
Chiba King.
Yari no Ame.
Chiri Chiri Cheese Aji.
I'm Mando!
BAU BAU!
Out to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!